I went to the Strasburg Parliament three
weeks ago I gave a speech on this I
predict exactly what would happen and it
was just totally ignored by the UK media
there is a common EU asylum policy mr.
Younker the commission president has
made it clear that basically anyone that
comes across the Mediterranean will be
resettled within the European Union
they've done completely the opposite to
what the Australians did back in 2008
when they faced the same problem I would
argue strongly there is a lot more we
should do to help those countries in
Africa we should get rid of the e use
tariff policies on their agricultural
products we should stop the rape and
pillage of African waters there's lots
we should do but I don't want us to be
part of a common EU asylum policy and
even if Mr Cameron attempts to resist
all they have to do in Italy is to give
people EU passports and then all of them
if they wish can come to Britain so I
think Cameron's first euro crisis has
started today it's a bit of
scaremongering going on there isn't
there a mr. Ferris European Commission
doesn't have the authority to enforce
such a plan and also the UK is not bound
to participate that there's no element
of compulsion that actually legally
exists once you come into the European
Union if people are accepted by other EU
states and given EU passports they are
then free to move to Britain this
actually gets to the whole point of why
you Kip says you cannot control
migration into Britain unless you
control your own borders and you can't
control your own borders as a member of
the EU so whatever the Home Office
statement says you know the Home Office
are saying we shouldn't be part of a
common external policy but we support
free movement within once people have
come in and be given EU passports there
is literally nothing we can do